yeah that's absolutely
right uh the home office have just
confirmed to us that they
uh that this this rescue search and
rescue operation started at about
4 00 a.m this morning uh that they
intercepted
four boats carrying 30 people in all as
you said now that
included 27 men a woman
and two children the rescue operation
lasted about three hours these people
were
on four small boat sky sources that they
looked
more like canoes than anything more
solid and as you say a very dangerous
and risky journey to undertake it was
a border force cutter and another patrol
vehicle another patrol vessel which
managed to bring
these people safely to shore where they
were medically checked over
and now they have all been uh put
through to an immigration
center where they will be interviewed in
due course
over the course of the morning we have
been hearing from
the various authorities involved in
finding these people
over the past couple of hours let me
just read you the statement that we
were given from the coast guard where
they said
uh hermeticus coast guard is only
concerned with preservation of life
rescuing those in trouble and bringing
them safely back to shore where they
will be handed over to the relevant
partner emergency services
or authorities we know in this case that
these people have now
been handed over to the immigration
services
now this is a significant number of
people
30 just this morning around a dozen
people
last weekend as well that is where
people just intercepted
on this side of the channel another
group of migrants were rescued off the
coast of france undertaking the same
journey
also over the course of last night